thank you  stop right there  who are you and how did you get in here  [Music]  the air is  underwater  my mother told stories about a place  like this a protected land with people  that never had to leave  never have to change who they were  what reason do you have to rebuild your  secret to the world I am not a woman who  enjoys or repeating herself who are you  I have many names  my people call me  but my enemies call me Namor  get out of my dorm get out  hey  good morning you do not take another  step toward me  see how they teach the children to treat  their guests  [Applause]  I like it hey hey hey hey put it down  put it yourself come on it's all right  princess small small girl  I am going to give you two options  you can come to wakanda conscious or  unconscious  you need to  meet super sort of way that you look  walking around here all that Ash on your  head  oh it's funny no it's not I told you not  good